You always have to be careful, whatever you do in any detoxification work or any
rife work, killing off any biotoxids, everything that is going to go out of
your body has to go through your detox pathways. So you're out running, you're
breathing really heavy, you are transferring things from your blood to the air
and you are expelling something. So your lungs are a detox pathway, right? You're
drinking lots of water and you're you're excreting through your kidneys, your
kidneys are a detox pathway. You're exercising a lot, you're sweating a lot,
your skin is a detox pathway. First question I ask everyone about patients, how
is your bowel movements? If you're not having daily bowel movements, you aren't
toxifying yourself. You are reabsorbing your toxins that you're expelling into the
colon. So super important, all our cancer patients, we have them doing coffee
edibas. So and then your liver, your liver, all these things have to go through
your liver. That's why I don't like cancer patients or any patients might take you
too many supplements because my philosophy is too much of a good thing is a bad
thing. Well this is really good, I read this book on it, this is supposed to be
really good. Well yeah, well does your body need it? That's the question. So you
have to have a way of testing that person to find out what they need even by
cancer patients. Both of them are on it just a few things. If you overwhelm the
liver detox pathways, you're going to be in trouble. So most people that are sick
chronically, part of the reason why they're sick is because, and I don't know which
came first, the chicken or the egg, their liver detox pathways are compromised.
There's different functional medicine tests that you can run. What is an
organics panel? It measures all your liver detox pathways and if they're compromised
or not. It's really kind of fun. I like to run that test on my patients because then
they can see right there. You know, you have four pathways that are blocked. You do
detox, you're just going to get sick. You're just going to circulate it through your
body. If you do chelation and you have blocked detox pathways, you'll pull it out
of the thyroid, let's say, and you're going to circulate in a road, it won't be
able to get out the liver and it's going to be deposited somewhere else. Not good.